bonjour je m'appelle adrien j'ai 27 ans
je suis acteur d'ailleurs je vous avez
peut-être vu j'ai fait pas mal de films
quand j'étais petit est debout chéri
j'ai l'impression qu'à 25 minutes
appartement a été saisie monsieur
palatine ne vous appartient plus le flux
ce qu'on n'avale pas la carte des gens
puissants une décision de justice
maintenant je bois je serai une carte
plutôt bien surtout en automne
[Musique]
vous foutez de ma gueule non
par exemple à la fois j'étais avec une
fille on s'embrassait il a rien pas un
soupçon de rigueur rien dans le slip
bon allez montrer monastique au à ok
mais quoi alors je rigole je chante quoi
je suis pas un truc de toi là-bas c'est
penser consulter on n'en sait pas de ma
mère est psy et raconte à ta vieille
mais bien pour la fête en fête
non adrien mon fils qui est des un-es de
lit chez lui donc il est revenu habiter
chez sa maman tu prends la drogue bon
enfin je fume un peu de crack à
stalingrad le samedi soir mais après ça
va aussi été black merci beaucoup
non désolé